[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey what is going on youtube hey it's
cameron with motion science and i'm here
today to talk to you uh about stylecraft
and answer questions and all that good
stuff
uh but i want to know from you guys
you can let me know you can see me and
hear me okay
see me and hear me okay
um and who's here today let me know
who's here what's going on we're hanging
out talking
about stylecraft i want to answer
questions uh maybe if i can answer any
general motion design questions for you
today
that's what i'm here to do
and uh
that's what it's all about today so it's
great to be here today um
tuesday
beautiful day in south florida
uh what's up laurent
it's all good all right awesome awesome
uh shanky west side what's up hey
uh ko you
ko you okay and okay awesome
uh aaron what's up cameron uh is it a
general q a or only about starcraft so
um it's a both it's both i'm here to
help whoever today
uh so i'm on here just talking answering
questions uh if you've got questions
about stylecraft great if you have
general design
motion design questions
i can help answer those as well
um
so yeah
darius what's up darius
yeah because this will probably be the
last like live i do on youtube for a
while
i'm still going to be like weekly videos
and things like that
but i'm going to take a break from
doing youtube lives for a while
and
refocus on some things and
um commit my time to stylecraft so
i'm gonna be going live in starcraft
more
to help out my students in there so
this will be like the like the big sign
off from my lives for a while
so any questions i can help you with
i want to help you with uh let me know
what you guys are working on anything
exciting anything cool i've been working
on some new
uh particle animations uh using trapcode
particular
uh which has been fun
i started working with trapcode
particular back in the day like when it
first came out when red giant was just
starting out and i've always loved that
that plug-in right the power of the
plug-in
and uh
getting back into to spend some more
time with it i haven't played around
with it for
quite some time now and
that'd be fun to design some things in
it so that's what i'm working on
right now what are you guys working on
what's going on with everybody else you
guys are kind of quiet today
uh motion designer do you sell your nfts
no i don't
i do not
i've been asked that a few times
uh but i have not
done that yet
got any advice for me i'd love to hear
it always open to things like that
aaron is still trying excuse me aaron is
still trying to sell my boss on red
giant well
um i'm a big fan of red giant i love
what they do i said i've used them since
the beginning
uh gosh i don't remember when they even
came out it's been so long ago but uh
big fan of trap code particular big fan
of magic bullets
um i love their stylized plugins now
that they came out with when they
released universe
which is fairly new you know last few
years
uh love universe but uh yeah i mean i
think fred giant creates amazing plugins
uh
co you let the proflose tips come back
please
i love them
uh you know what those are actually for
sale now on my website
um i bundled 25 of the best ones
together and they're seven bucks
through motionscience.tv
so that's where they're at
uh 25 they're called the 25
pro
quick tips for after effects in cinema
4d lite
those are the old proflows quick tips
that
there was more than 25 there was a lot
of them but those were the ones that got
the most results for people and people
loved so you can actually get this on
the website for only seven bucks so it's
pretty cheap
uh schenke westside what do you think is
easier to learn and works better with
after effects what do you mean by that
what do you think is easier to learn and
works better with after effects
uh don't quite understand the question
maybe rephrase it
um
what do you think is easier to learn and
works better with after effects make
plugins is that ever talking about
uh laurent still working on my five-day
challenge animation the feedback from
starcraft community helped it's looking
good awesome
yeah that was really cool lauren what
you posted in there
i really loved the color palette that
you came up with that was really cool
uh
ali
i did the batman style frame awesome
the batman style frame that's amazing
haven't seen batman yet but uh the title
i've seen for batman's really awesome
oh
shanky west side blender or cinema 4d so
i don't use blender
uh i use cinema 4d
um i've heard
different things from different people
some people love blender some people
love cinema 4d
uh personally i'm
cinema 4d because it's um
used in
real world production experience or
teams i shouldn't say experience um
it's got support for it blender doesn't
as of last i heard it didn't um
cinema 4d is more of a pro app i mean
you can do amazing things with
blender i've seen some awesome stuff but
um
from a pro standpoint it's going to be
cinema 4d all day long
so i'm sure blender will get there one
of these days
but uh
yeah the majority of my students use
cinema 4d sorry there are a couple that
use blender
uh daniel
how's it going cameron it's going good
mr daniel cruz great to see you here
today
just uh talking shop answering questions
all that kind of stuff
shanky was said are you planning to make
a course on it i have a course on cinema
4d over at motionscience.tv it's called
the cinema 4d quick start course it gets
you up and running very quickly
uh with cinema 4d
people who have taken it absolutely love
it
no courses on blender because i just
like i said i don't use it
so
definitely check out the cinema 40 quick
start course over at motionscience.tv
uh aaron one thing that has proved
incredibly effective in my motion design
journey is seeing videos on youtube that
zone in on one effect or technique your
video on 3d camera movement was so
helpful
thank
you um
yeah i mean i think that's a great
comment aaron
uh learning
one effector technique's great
the thing with
the way i teach things through motion
science is that
i want you to learn to think creatively
for yourself right and not have to the
problem i have with most youtube videos
is that they show you a tech technique
that's very specific and it's like
here's how you make this exact same
thing you're going to enter this number
and this number you're going to click
xyz you're going to preview this this
and this and you're going to have the
exact same thing i did
what i try to teach through motion
science is how to think creatively so i
show the process
but it's more about okay here's the
overall creative approach to this
project
here's how i created my example but i
want you to go and create your own
example using your own design assets or
whatever it is and create your own thing
so or here's how to use an effect
in a generalized sense
versus
one specific
technique and i would even say with a 3d
camera technique video
um
yeah it was on
you know one specific thing the 3d
camera but i showed a lot of different
gosh because i made that video many
years ago
and it's still
because it's so
um
[Music]
it's not specific on here's how you
create this look with this camera it's
more of an over reaching overall
approach to the creative of using a 3d
camera and what it can do it's still
super valuable
and
applicable
today five years later right
because it is kind of a timeless
approach to to using something so that's
kind of what i do with with motion
science some of my videos i put out
there are very can be specific like the
one i just released
last friday the fun with loops and
cinema 4d
um if you haven't seen that video check
it out it's fun it's simple
it kind of shows you how to create this
very specific thing but that's kind of
an anomaly i would say for motion
science
videos it's more of an overall creative
approach to things
and my
to finish what you're saying aaron
that's where i think
people get the most um
i think there's like something in my
shirt here it's like poking me sorry
the heck is it
oh it's a piece of tape my daughter
probably put it here
interesting
um anyway sorry um so anyways you know
like
it's okay to learn a specific technique
or effect but learn to think creatively
and don't just copy what you see in a
tutorial kind of take what you've
learned and apply it to your own thing
and go out there and and learn your own
creative approach to using that effect
or technique
um motion design nft is good money if
you're a big artist i think or it's a
lie just marketing
well you know motion designer i've seen
i have a lot of people i know
friends that have left
kind of freelancing to go design nfts
full-time
the majority of them don't make very
much money
but there's a few that have done really
well for themselves so and i'm really
proud of them
so you can make a lot of money with it
absolutely
um
but you just have to be i wouldn't throw
everything away
to go create nfts i would still
focus in on whatever it is you're into
and like if you're a freelancer or
you've got a full-time job stick with
that maybe try nfts on the side
in the evenings whatever
um
[Music]
artem
uh hi can you recommend some books for
motion designers and where you find
inspiration
so i'm not a big
book reader
unless it comes to like self-development
which could come back to motion design
absolutely but it's more about like
mindset and things like that
so
um
there's a book out there by austin
saylor
that's pretty good
um
and every time someone asks me the name
of the book i can never remember
but it's by austin saylor it's the only
book i think he's written maybe he's
written two books now it's a really good
book about style frames and things like
that um
but other than that inspiration for me
comes from sites like pinterest
uh sites like behance
instagram
[Music]
art of the title it's a great site
there's a lot of other ones out there as
well
don't get wrapped up in just sticking
with social media only to get
inspiration because you're seeing a
small slice of motion design
in social media right so like let's say
instagram
depending on who you follow instagram
has an algorithm and it's just pushing
artists that are all the same type of
styles and things that it thinks you're
going to like because it wants you to
keep scrolling and clicking on things so
you're only going to see a slice of what
that genre of motion design is when
there's all these other areas of motion
design out there right um
like you know motion design is so broad
it's visual effects it's 2d character
animation it's vector animation it's two
and a half t it's 3d it's particle
systems
um it's film titles it's
show opens it's sports graphics it's
theater graphics it's live venue
graphics it's museum graphics
the list goes on and on and on right so
be careful with social media
thinking that this is the only type of
motion graphics that exist out there or
this is what's popular or trendy now
because it's just showing you a slice
of what it thinks you want to see
but i like to build boards and pinterest
if you don't follow motion science on
pinterest
100 go do it
i create boards all the time for
different
things that are inspiring to me
typography different types of typography
colors textures
titles
the list goes on and on and on right so
pinterest is a huge one for me behance
i'm starting to create more boards on
behance
and with instagram i like to take
screenshots on my phone and then put
those screenshots into folder structures
in my iphone so that i can go back to
those folders and reference
inspiration stuff or screen recordings
as well
you can also get inspiration from any
place like architecture when i travel i
always get highly inspired
architecture magazines
you know movies
um there's a lot of different places to
be inspired from
uh to to see stylecraft see daniel cruz
stylecraft and your cinemath 4d course
looks sick
i'm stuck between deciding which to take
first i've taken school of motions from
a 40 boot camp course but finding a
scent a bit overwhelming wondering if
your course is better of course my
course is better right if you're talking
about cinema 4d
i haven't taken their courses i think
their courses are great
so i have a lot of students who come
into stylecraft
that have taken school of motion courses
nothing but good things to say about
them
i think stylecraft is a great compliment
check out school of motion when you're
ready come to starcraft
it's a step above in terms of
creating cinematic motion design and
things like that
uh hi richard great to have you here
aaron last two from me no worries aaron
keep asking those questions uh what is
the purpose behind frame rates of 2398
and 29.97 when 24 and 30 seem like more
commonly used frame rates also what are
the most useful plugins paid in free
um purpose behind frame rates 2398 and
20 2997 has to do with um
television
for the most part i guess that would be
an easy way to explain it
it's a
thing with how the frames work on tv
to get i i'm not gonna get into the
technical
i don't even remember the whole
technical jargon i used to back in the
day um because i don't use 2997 or 2398
anymore um
the only time i ever use those frame
rates is when a video editor is working
for something for television who says i
need it at these frame rates or it's
something that's being projected on a tv
and that projection system requires
those frame rates
otherwise i'm pretty much sticking with
24 frames a second or 30.
24 frames per second is you know more
film
motion
30 is more which you see on tv
i'm not a friend of frank
i'm not a
fan of 60 i feel like it's too smooth
so 2398 2997 is just more for
interlacing is what they call it
so i mean unless you're requested
specifically to create with those frame
rates then don't worry about it
uh what are the most
useful paid
and free plugins
so my absolute favorite set of plugins
is sapphire from boris fx
every pro that i know uses boris effects
in some capacity and i've used them for
a long long time
so boris effect sapphire is amazing red
giant plugins are pretty good they're up
there
those would be my two right off the top
of my head that i think are
definitely worth getting
there's a lot of other ones that are
very specific
to um certain things you're trying to do
like plug in everything it's got some
pretty cool plugins like deep glow and
stuff like that they're a little bit
cheaper i guess
but still if it was like between plug-in
everything's deep glow and boris
sapphire's
glow effect i'd pick glow effect from
sapphire all day long
um
free plug-ins animation composer
mr horse dot tv
animation composer it's free to start
then you can buy packs for it
that
you can add into it so it comes with
like a bunch of free presets it's like a
it's like an animator right for text and
a lot of times people just think of it
as a text animator but you can actually
use it for like the 3d camera you can
use it for 3d layers things like that
you can really go beyond what
it shows in the examples
and then it has a lot of add-ons like
you can add textures to it and um
shape animations and things like that
and it's just a really fast
click-through
whoa
camera just freaked out there
what's going on
hold on here
let's get back in there
there we go
um it's just really fast and it's it's
awesome
um other free plugins uh plug in
everything quick chromatic aberration
two is pretty good for a com for an
aberration effect is which is used for
finishing a lot of times
um it's pretty good
and
i don't know
top of my head that's it i have a lot
more paid plugins right that i use but
the thing too i want you to keep in mind
is i don't want you to get wrapped up
thinking that you have to have plugins
to do
uh motion design right so a lot of times
i tell my students that
you know start without plugins right
just start with the basics
with that are built into after effects
and don't worry about third-party
plug-ins because when you get wrapped up
in third-party plugins
that's when you get
into thinking that you have to have all
these free or paid plugins to make your
work look good and your work's not going
to look any better than it already does
you need to understand how to make good
motion design to begin with and then you
can apply the effects over the top of it
to kind of finish it and polish it and
make it that much better
the only time you're going to need
to consider third-party plugins
when you're not
really good at design yet is
for a very specific
use case
like
[Music]
if you need to create
a physics
simulation or something like that
there's a plug-in called newton
uh that helps with physics and after
effects or
uh you need to create particle systems
then i would highly recommend trapcode
particular
but those are specific use cases
the last one on earth hello what's going
on
hello
hello
um
daryl what's up daryl
uh cameron sorry i'm late are there any
cinema 4d light only intensive courses
for folks who don't have can afford the
full version thank you
uh yeah stylecraft
it's not intensive but i
make use a lot of cinema 4d light in
stylecraft because it does come with
adobe after effects if you have a paid
subscription
and it's super powerful right so i still
tend to
go to cinema 4d lite over the full blown
version
because the majority of the 3d projects
i'm working on
are simple
in terms of 3d
and i can get away with cinema 4d light
and after effects right
so
uh cinema 4d light only
would 100 be stylecraft i also have some
specific
cinema 4d like courses
um
[Music]
there are many courses that uh i don't
offer publicly anymore
darryl but if you email me
hello at motionscience.tv
[Music]
that
and let me know you know hey i hit you
up on on the youtube q a i can send you
a link to some of these cinema 4d lite
courses
some of them are cinema 4d
full version plus they include the
the
supplementation for the light version
only
like i have a course on projection
mapping with cinema 4d and 740 lite
i have some courses on um i have a
course on on wireframe renders on a
cinema 40 that people really liked a lot
so email me hello at motionscience.tv
and i can send you a link to some of
those cinema 40 like courses or i would
100 recommend stylecraft stylecraft
registration is open right now for those
of you who don't know
that's the reason i'm here live today
registration is open until april 2nd
and i only open up registration twice a
year
so we talk
very deeply in stylecraft about after
effects and cinema 4d late
if you haven't checked out some
stylecraft daryl it's motionscience.tv
stylecraft which is s-t-y-l-e
c-r-a-f-t
d-d
[Music]
uh
what's up ray rnyc
a little late but you're here great to
have you here
what's up
last one on earth miss being in one of
your lives
appreciate that i was saying a little
bit ago this is going to be my last live
to the general public here on youtube
for a while
i'm gonna go back to
spending more time with my stylecraft
students
so you probably won't see me live for
for a while but it's good to be here
today thanks so much for everything you
do
you're more than an inspiration i
appreciate that one
um
[Music]
uh daryl awesome
hope to hear from you
who else has got a question for me
fantasy engineered yep cinema 4d has
particles and much more learning
learning is the key yes but at some
point you have to put your learning into
practice as well
my dog's freaking out
i see a lot of motion designers get
caught up in
learn learn learn and never implement so
it's important that you have that kind
of balance
between learning and implementing but
yeah and there's a lot of learning
involved for sure
christopher what is your best course
regarding creating youtube videos for
infotainment
um
[Music]
well i don't have a course specifically
on uh
youtube videos
again what i teach in stylecraft can be
carried across to any genre of video so
my students in stylecraft and youtube
being one of those okay so like i had an
editor
a youtube editor
who was in starcraft a few sessions ago
who had a lot of success learning
just overall how to make his youtube
graphics better right that's what it was
all about it's just learning how to
create
visually eye-pleasing graphics
easy
easier right and
that are more fulfilling creatively
fulfilling for you and look better for
your audience
and uh he was he worked for a youtuber
and his job was just to create you know
to edit and create the graphics for the
infotainment
and um
it was fun to watch his journey
uh through stylecraft just to watch his
graphics get better so
um i've had people who are youtubers
come through stylecraft i've had people
who are working on titles
come through stylecraft a lot of
different editors um infographic artists
artists who work for tv stations
artists who work for agencies for
studios
freelancers who are generalists
i've had 3d artists come through who
specialize in 3d who want to learn how
to make their 3d look even better
because i teach a lot of finishing
techniques in stylecraft
because i've always been kind of
known for
making my work really stand out
and easy
what i teach are easy to apply
techniques
so i would recommend starcraft
iglox i watched your presentation for
your ae academy a lot of time
and you said you learned
after effects without any youtube
tutorials or any help how did you do it
uh so when i taught myself after effects
um i talked a lot about this in a
free challenge i just did but
essentially i had a book
so when i started learning after effects
youtube wasn't even a thing yet i
started learning in 1999
or 98
right there i think it's
um
i had a book with a cd and it was very
basic and it was like here's after
effects and here's the program and this
is what you can do by clicking these
buttons and so i did that and i spent a
lot of time
just experimenting with after effects
and experimenting with animation i
started with animation and i created a
lot of spec work for myself this isn't
this is not work that i was
going out to clients and saying i'm
going to do free work for you this was
stuff that i wanted to create for myself
so i essentially
built my first demo reel
making like
taking making a fake logo for a company
that didn't exist
and animating it in an interesting way
or or working with like a particle
simulation and stuff like that
i created a lot of spec work for myself
so i would work my day job and i would
come home at night
and i would
push buttons and practice and see what i
could create
uh in after effects right
what could i make move
so i focused a lot of time on animation
[Music]
eventually built a demo reel
out of spec work that i had made myself
uh started a little company
built with my buddy and built another
spec reel that had
the majority spec work and then a little
bit of paid work in there and then i got
hired full time at a post house
where i was paid full time to do motion
grant was paid
as a motion graphics designer full time
um
again made more spec work
had a little bit more paid client work
and i made a third reel and then i went
freelance
into the
professional world my clients at that
point were pretty large and then i
started teaching myself design
principles
so that i could make my compositions and
my animations look better
right so i could understand
how
the compositions how they what's going
to make them look better because like
you know a designer could hand me a
still frame a style frame and say here's
the beginning of the animation and now
put it into motion so once i put into
motion things are moving to different
parts of the screen and i still needed
to understand
where they needed to be on screen to
make them look good
and so i started teaching myself design
principles eventually moved into style
frame design
and then all of a sudden i was a
freelancer doing design and motion and i
think it's super important
again this is why i have stylecraft the
course
because as a motion designer we need to
understand motion
and design right that's why there's two
words there
so that's how i did it just creating
spec work and teaching myself if i could
go start all over again
i would have had a mentor
like myself to teach me because my
journey would have been sped up
so much faster
i would have learned things so much
quicker if i had someone telling me hey
this is what you need to do
to make this look better or this is what
you need to do this is what you need to
focus on right now you're really good at
this but you need to focus on this
instead so i didn't have a course to
teach me i didn't have a mentor
and i learned on my own it took me a
long time this is why i've created
motion science this is why i
specifically created stylecraft to give
you mentorship and training
to make you better as a motion designer
faster
uh let's see here please tell the most
please tell about the most unorthodox
advertising you've seen i don't i have
no idea
um every time i play video games i tend
to see motion graphics people have
worked on the game etc wondering how
does one land a job in the video game
industry as a motion designer it's all
who you know when it's creating a reel
right daniel all i have to do is create
a reel
that is the work that you want more of
right so it's this endless cycle
you are passionate about creating this
type of work so you create it yourself
you build a demo reel out of that type
of work you put that demo reel on the
internet for people to see
eventually someone hires you and pays
you to do that type of work
you your reel gets better because you're
replacing elements on your reel with
that new work
and you have a new reel that goes out to
the world and you get better and better
jobs better and better pay
and you end up in the industries you
want to be in
so
you know my demo rails were the same way
i built stuff that i was super
passionate about
and made it real and got hired so you
can get a job in any industry
if you put you know your heart and soul
into it and you create
pieces that belong in that industry
uh the good old days
yeah i think there's still the good old
days right
what are we missing out on today i mean
dude today
i would say today is the good old days
in terms of being a motion designer when
i started out i was i went freelance
remote remote freelance in 2007
and i was in the middle of the country
right middle of the united states and
for those of you who aren't in the u.s
you either had to work you had to live
in new york city or you had to live in
los angeles
to get all the big jobs right you had to
be there i couldn't do that because i
had a family and i had small kids
and i was based in the middle of the
country in kansas city so
i had huge balls to go out there and say
no i'm a remote freelancer and you can
hire me
but i'm going to stay right here and
work for you and that's what i did
and it was super challenging a lot of
people would say
we love your work if you'll come out
here we will hire you
but if not we're not going to so you
know i missed out on a ton of work today
you can be a remote freelancer all day
long and get hired all day long
like it's expected that you're going to
be a remote freelancer so to me this is
the good old days right the
opportunities today
are a hundred times what they were when
i started out even a hundred times what
they were in the mid-2010s
right so we are in the good old days
uh sedgwick edward hey what's up edward
starcraft is a great course the elements
of principles of design alone enter my
work every day
it also forces you out of the ruts and
techniques you usually gravitate towards
i appreciate that edward edwards was one
of the
in one of the first groups of stylecraft
back in the day
great to see you
thanks for being here
uh
[Music]
uh how do i get expertise in motion
design
um well you um
you practice you take courses
uh if you if you want to you you spend
all your time on youtube learning but
that's the problem with youtube again is
that there's so many different videos
out there and you have to piecemeal your
your learning together right so you're
jumping from this course from this
youtube creator to this one to this one
to this one you're jumping all around
hopefully you find a few that you really
like
and you can piecemeal your learning
together
or you can join a course
and you can get guidance and a path to
follow to learn motion design and that's
how you become an expert you also
practice what you learn
and you put it into practice every day
every week
practice just a little bit and before
you know it you'll get there
uh
yeah how can we get uh expert as a
motion graphics designer so take
stylecraft that's how you get uh become
an expert in motion graphic design
take stylecraft
that is my answer for you
diya
i think i pronounced your name correctly
who else has got a question for me today
starcraft registration is open right now
it's open until
uh was four more days closes on saturday
april 2nd
at midnight
i want to get as many people in the
course as possible
in stylecraft i teach you through
training and mentorship
i teach you principles and elements of
design i make it fun
you get to see some really cool examples
of what i teach
i make i always make it fun and i always
make it easy right i'm trying to make it
as easy as possible
for you to learn
these techniques
it's not about being trendy
it's about learning classic
uh fundamentals that will serve you
in any area of motion design that you
want to go into
and it's not about learning what's super
hot today it's about learning these
again these fundamentals that
will serve you years from now
what i love about starcraft as well is
the community there's a private
community it's not a facebook community
it's a private community
that is um on a new platform
edwards you did not get to experience
that unfortunately i'm sorry but
uh the new community is awesome
and uh super interactive
we post our work we talk about our work
we could critique each other's work
super uh loving community you know like
no one's there hating on anybody
the very
i think i've had two
one one occasion of someone hating on
people and
they were gone right i don't i don't
support that
and uh
it's all good
what else can i answer for you guys
today
you got me on here for a few more
minutes
a few more minutes
no one told me what they were working on
i told you i was working on a particle
system design
getting back into particle systems love
it
working with trapcode particular i tried
to play around for a while with um what
was that other system that came out
stardust
i saw a lot of potential in that but i
feel like it's kind of died off right i
don't see it so much anymore
and at the end of the day
i still think that trapcode particular
was like where it's at
they got it down
i think maybe they picked up some some
ideas from stardust that they've
implemented as well
which is great
well everybody you guys are being pretty
quiet today so
um if i don't have any more questions oh
here's another one
i'm gonna wrap it up if i don't get any
more questions
uh is element 3d useful for doing motion
design yeah
it is i i own element 3d
and i've only used it one time in a
project though one time and that was
because i needed to create a very quick
um
text animation 3d text animation that um
i didn't want to go to cinema 4d for it
for some reason i don't remember why
actually
but
i used it it did a great job i feel like
the the ui is a little bit clunky for me
to to wrap my head around
but i do know some motion designers who
use element 3d who are amazing with it i
think you just for me i just didn't
spend enough time with it
so if you want a simplified 3d program
to use right inside of after effects i
would 100 recommend element 3 element 3d
uh daryl what is your opinion on motion
graphics in the vr realm i think it's
it's another area that motion graphics
are going to explode into i think it's
they're completely necessary for vr
um
you know that's the thing that we talk
about sometimes motion graphics is is a
booming
industry right it's only growing
video content is king these days it's
only getting more and more popular and
with video content comes more and more
motion graphics that has to tie into
that video content same goes for like vr
ar
as we move into that those kind of
worlds
moving graphics gonna be even more
important than they are today so i think
it's huge for vr
lawrence when is the next feedback
friday i'm going to get it scheduled uh
pretty quickly here
um
[Music]
yeah we'll get it scheduled real soon
uh how do i go about targeting companies
who specifically use title designers
like is there a list of producers i can
get or something lol
yeah so we talked about this in our
career coaching community
which is another it's a community i
offer that opens up a couple times a
year you should join the waitlist if
you're interested ray
um
it's it's essentially reaching out to
companies that you're very like super
interested in so like if you're
interested in like elastic or prologue
or whatever like a big title design
company
find out who their executive producer is
and get the email and then you send them
a cold
basically a cold email you keep it
really short and you say like hey
you know this is who i am this is what
i'm about
uh really
dig what you guys are doing with your
title work at such and such company um i
would love to have the opportunity to
work with you in some capacity here's a
link to my reel that link is hyperlinked
go straight to your reel
you know thanks for your time you keep
it very short
two paragraphs two small paragraphs at
the most like two to three sentences per
paragraph uh you're telling a little bit
about who you are because a producer
wants to know kind of a little bit about
you very briefly and the biggest thing
is they want to see you're real they
want to see what your skill sets like
and that's all it is it takes an email
you're not sending out mass emails
you're targeting very specific people
and sending an email to those people
you need to build a demo reel that
includes title work if you want to get
paid to do it and if you don't have any
title work to show then you need to
create spec work
and build a reel like i was talking
about earlier
and that's literally creating like you
know a five threes three to five second
scene here and here and here it's not
like creating entire title sequences and
then editing those together into a demo
reel that's not it at all
it's it's about
creating these mini scenes right so
let's say you could come up with
five different ideas for five different
title sequences okay
five title sequences one scene from each
title sequence so for instance i could
do like i could make up a fake horror
movie i could make up a fake love story
a fake sci-fi movie story a fake um
thriller or crime
whatever it is and from that
i would create one scene for each title
sequence so it's essentially kind of
like
these are you know they're made up
scenes
but they're in that genre of whatever it
is and you're putting together these
five scenes into a reel and then if you
show five seconds in each of these clips
that's 25 second reel plus your intro
and outro you've got a 35 second reel
which is enough to get you hired
you know ideally a reel of 60 seconds
but if it's 30 seconds of just high
quality work that can get you hired
you just need to go out there and find
the the producers though it's not too
hard
just search them out there's no list
that i know of
uh will you one day teach a class for
designing 3d for social media instagram
tick tock snapchat i feel like companies
are scared to do more three for social
uh i mean no i mean that's what again
this is what stylecraft is about it's
about an overall approach i'm not about
teaching a specific
like here's how you make 3d for for
instagram it's not like go search out
youtube or you know somebody else for
that
that's not what i'm you can learn that
but then you're going to learn one
specific skill that can only be applied
to that specific thing if you learn an
overall approach
daniel to like motion design and you
understand
what it takes to make great motion
design then you can apply that to
anything you can apply that to social
media like snapchat or tick tock you can
apply that to film titles you can apply
it to sports graphics you can apply it
to tv network packages promos
anything infographics you know
documentaries whatever it is
it can be applied to anything you have
to understand the overall
approach to motion design
and then you can apply it
to anything i think i said that three
times now
uh motions are i love your streams thank
you
uh paul is it a live course or work at
your own speed what level of expertise
do you need great question paul
uh no it is not live so there's there's
70 plus videos always 70 plus because
it's changed a little bit i think
there's 74 videos now maybe 74 lessons
right and these are lessons ranging from
i think the shortest lesson maybe 10
minutes
don't quote me on that
the longest lesson's maybe an hour
but the average is you know 20 30
minutes i think to 40 minutes maybe 20
to 40 minutes i can't remember
i try to keep it as condensed as
possible because i know we are precious
you know time is precious to all of us
so it's a work at your own speed course
but the lessons are are dropped into
your library
every three to four days
so you start stylecraft you have a
handful of lessons to get through it's
kind of like preliminary things that you
learn
and then after that in three days you
get a set of lessons on texture
four days later you get a set of lessons
on color three days later you get a set
of lessons on
line and shape and it goes in in all
these lessons they build upon each other
okay so the whole thing the whole point
of this is i've laid these lessons out
in a specific order on purpose because i
want you to go through each and every
lesson
in order be and not jump around right i
want you to learn these these
these lessons because starcraft lessons
build upon each other as we move through
the course
and it's important that you don't skip a
lesson because there may be one critical
thing in that lesson that you pick up on
that you're going to need in a future
lesson
so that's how it works so i've had
people who come into stylecraft who
within 12 weeks because it's it's all
released within a 12-week period within
12 weeks they've stayed up
every week and they finish in 12 weeks
i've had people who have come in and it
takes them over a year or two years even
to do it because they i have other busy
schedules
and they take the lessons when they need
to so you have lifetime access to the
course so at the end of the day it's up
to you how quickly or slowly you want to
move through the course i do do
live
things called feedback fridays where we
talk about the work
and
again
if your work is posted in the community
i'll talk about it
if it's something you can attend live
great if you can it's recorded and it's
in the community so
that's the only live aspect of it is
when i go live in the community
um what level expertise do you need i've
worked with a lot of different levels
i've worked with
people who have
very little experience the big the only
prerequisite is that you know after
effects right you need to be comfortable
enough with after effects that you can
get around the program
that's all you have to have
so as long as you can open up after
effects and you know what the different
panels are and how to like apply effects
and how to set keyframes and things like
that then you will have success in
stylecraft
so i've worked with people who just have
the basics of after effects down
to people who are mid-level to i've
worked with creative directors of
very large companies
that have gone through stylecraft so
it really
is all different levels
i've also had people who joined
stylecraft who
um
have also taken
signed up for after effects academy one
two and three at the same time because
they didn't know after effects
um
and that's been a great combination as
well
how do i follow your youtube video
playlist to enter into motion design
field so
um i mean
i'm not a youtube expert but i have a
lot of playlists here
um they're not
there's no real way there's no like
course set up here on youtube uh the
videos are just kind of like a different
playlist throughout
uh depending on what kind of area you're
wanting to learn about so like there's
playlists about after effects there's
playlists about
uh cinema 4d there's playlists about
titles there's playlists about designing
um there's playlists about effects
there's a lot of content on the youtube
channel
a lot of content so
um but there's no like set
course per se on youtube if you want
like a streamlined course of path then i
would highly recommend that you sign up
for one of my courses
the camera's just drifting around there
i've got my ai camera going here it's
pretty cool
it's got a cameraman built into it so it
kind of follows me around
very fun okay
uh jaden what's the future of motion
design like uh well i think it's huge
i could ask that a lot i think it's huge
i know it's going to be huge like i said
video is king content video content is
king and with that comes motion graphics
if you look at like
social media right there's more and more
graphics being put into social media
um back in the day social media was a
pretty picture a pretty still image that
it's moved all into video right it's all
about the video and now it's moving into
uh you gotta have these graphics over
your video and
so just from that standpoint social
media
uh future of motion design is very very
bright uh in terms of like you know
films are always going to be here
television is always going to be here
motion design is huge in that sports
uh it's becoming really really big and
like the whole like
museum space the whole space for um
like
interactive uh exhibits or even like
walking into a hotel right you walk into
a hotel and there's this beautiful
display of motion graphics happening in
front of you in the lobby
maybe you interact with things or not
you can check in
ui is is getting big into motion design
of course
i mean literally every field i mean even
like inside your car right
the way that things come pop up and move
and things like that i mean motion
design in the future is only going to be
bigger and bigger and bigger
it's funny because when i started in
this industry
i tried to explain to people what
motion graphics are
and it was really challenging and today
it's still somewhat challenging when
they're like what do you do i'm like i
make motion graphics like what is that
but i can i can relate it to something
like hey do you watch a tv show or
uh you're a big football fan well when
you walk into the stadium you see these
graphics moving or you're watching on tv
and you see graphics like you can relate
it's easier to relate motion design to
things now because it's becoming more
and more prevalent
uh you're so good thanks for your
providing your information you are
welcome
uh do you think a lot of ai stuff will
be implemented maybe
maybe motion zones will be out of jobs
uh no not anytime soon
i think the field of art is one of those
that ai
uh
is got a long ways to go
before it can kind of take people out of
this
field
um
so i mean like like right now i pay to
use an ai um
script writing software that's really
powerful right it's super powerful it's
amazing what this thing can do
but there's still like a need for people
to write right like there's ai script
writing software but there's at the same
time it's like i can do so much with it
but
for certain use cases
i'm going to go out and hire a writer
who specializes in this whatever that
may be same for motion design
maybe ai is going to get good enough
where it can start
i don't know animating a logo or
adding
your name to a video or something like
that i don't know
but at the end of the day when you want
some specialized motion design for a
specific project you're going to go out
to a human being who can create that for
you very quickly
and do a really stellar job of creating
it
so no i don't think i think that's also
fear-based and i don't believe in you
know being fearful that oh i better not
learn this because it's just going to go
away i think it's here for a long time
to stay
yeah great point brandon uh branding and
marketing is something ai can't do
100
and jaden going back to your question
like you're your uh avatar says smile so
like
you know let's smile about it i don't i
don't see anything
detrimental with ai and motion design
i just saw a um a still image that ai
designed uh for like it was essentially
like an art painting and it was so weird
and so bad
uh it was interesting to see it
yeah it was weird
any more questions today
anymore
what can i help you with
uh where am i from so i'm originally
from the middle of the u.s kansas city
right in the middle of the united states
as i said that was a real challenge for
me when i started out in motion design
because
number one
it was there was no very few companies
in the midwest that did motion graphics
number two
uh it was super challenging to get
remote work
but uh now i'm living in south florida
where it's warm and sunny all the time
and i love it
so yeah
uh nice zoom on that drink there yeah
that's the ai cameraman
uh yeah you see many laborers are out of
jobs in these giant amazon showrooms all
the tech machines took over they're even
doing deliveries via drones yeah because
that's like a a job that i hate to say
it but anybody can do that job right i
can go in there i can move things around
and i can deliver things
not everyone can do
uh
motion design
we all you know those of us who are in
this industry have a unique talent
that we're exploring
and improving upon
so
no this is not something and i've read
articles too about um
you know like how art artists and i mean
it listed like these different
categories of people and who would be
like the last be replaced by machines
and it's like artists were like towards
the very end
who knows
uh no i did not move to a retirement
community brandon
no
no
there are many of those around here
actually where i live uh it's a lot of
families so
i had never been to where i moved to
in south florida it's really close to
miami
so
lots of families here i live in my own
little bubble i love it
prefer this any day over the cold
in the midwest so
all righty roo
well
any final questions i can answer i hope
to see
as many of you as possible in stylecraft
again
like i said
registration is closing april 2nd
at midnight
and
i've already got a lot of people have
joined
i am going to limit it to
a certain amount of people because
there's only one of them there's one of
me and many of you so for me to help as
many people as possible
i have to keep the class somewhat small
will you be getting into designing for
vr
i feel it might be a big thing for brand
soon um you know at this point i don't
have any plans to specifically get in
the vr design um but i'm not opposed to
it
absolutely
yeah i think as these you know the
metaverse stuff kind of takes off more
you know we'll see obviously brands are
moving into that
web 3.0 gets me really excited nfts are
exciting to me
but i see nfts in a different
area rather than just being used for art
i see a lot of different applications
for nfts that i think will be huge
um
good time i hope more people post their
work in the community yeah and lauren so
you join kind of by yourself so that's
kind of like in the past we've always
had these groups right where big groups
come in at a time and um
there's a lot of activity you came in in
between a lot of things
so
which is another reason lauren that we
haven't had a feedback friday for a
little bit here
uh because i don't have enough work to
really talk about uh posting in the last
month
or talk about uh critiquing so
we'll get one up here pretty soon
jaden how much do you think an average
motion designer can earn yearly
um
well there's some statistics out there
i think full-time
the average salary is like 65 000
in the u.s
that's a full-time employee a freelancer
can make
more than that
it really just depends on like what
route you want to go you know
as a full-time freelancer i was making
multiple six figures
freelancing by
myself so that's super easy
i know several full-time
a buddy of mine just got a full-time job
in la
and i think what do you say he's getting
180
he's a more of a senior level
but he went from
no experience in motion design to
joining stylecraft to going freelance
after stylecraft to getting a full-time
job to moving up again to another
full-time job it's only been three years
i think since he started from zero
experience and he's now a senior
creative art director
and i want to say his pay was 180 i
think
maybe it was more than that
uh and he could still go up above beyond
that too so
that's pretty good and but you know for
65 000 that's more of like your
junior level motion designers
uh daniel i wanted to create an aztec
title sequence of a fake show
uh
i don't know how to pronounce that king
fighting the colonizers but in the style
of the man in the high castle intro so
in order to decide which to take
stylecraft or cinema 4d
well i mean you can learn
again i'd go back to stylecraft i mean
you can learn it's going to take
understanding cinema 4d like modeling
and that kind of stuff to to create
like
some of the models you see in that title
sequence i i i vaguely remember that
title sequence i know i've referenced it
a couple of times but i can't remember
the exact
sequence of that title sequence the
exact imagery
but at the end of the day anyone can
create models and animate them in cinema
4d it's it's creating how that
what the look the look and feel of the
title sequence is it's creating
the the mood the atmosphere the story
behind it that's all
more important than just actually
modeling things and that's stylecraft
so um it's super important that you
understand you know
story
to be able to create a title sequence so
again for that that show i don't know if
the 3d modelers actually
you know just created the models and
handed them off to like the motion
designers or how that process worked but
100 stylecraft
there are some quality designers
offering cheap prices they are
destroying the market how can we compete
with that every quality designer i know
is charging a premium
so i'm not sure where you're referencing
um
you know if you're referencing sites
like upwork i i tend to tell people to
stay away from upwork as a motion
designer
that's not
the ideal market for motion designers so
go work for a studio become a freelancer
full-time work for a studio work for a
corporation
work for someone who's going to value
your unique skill set
and that's where you're gonna have the
most success
so there are people out there like on
fiverr and upwork uh maybe some other
sites that their prices are so low that
it does it does damage to the market
but i don't focus on that
and they're gonna get a certain type of
client that you do not want right
they're gonna get a client who doesn't
value
ultimately their skill set
um what they're capable of delivering
whereas i'm going to only focus on
people who value
high production
you know well thought out design
all that kind of stuff
okay everybody i'm gonna wrap this one
up um i appreciate everyone being here
today
um
oh looks like i got one more question
how do you stay focused doing a niche
from all the distractions of other work
that you could be doing specific
specifically when a client asks for it
i'm trying to do only fooly work
well i mean at this you have to do the
work that pays the bills
you know so i understand like
for your situation moose4d um i would
pay the bills during the day and on
nights and the weekends when i can get
away
that's when i'm going to be focused on
creating my own spec work around fooey
work and building a reel out of that and
starting to put that out to people and
then you're going to eventually get
those people to pay you to do that type
of work
but
you know we all have to put in our time
to like pay the bills
until there's that turning point and
eventually there will be that turning
point where you do get paid to do the
footy work so
um you can also turn jobs down you know
you can always turn jobs down you don't
have to take every job that's offered to
you so all right my friends uh thank you
so much for being here today
and appreciate each and every one of you
i appreciate all the questions i got
asked today
all the thumbs up it was great uh highly
encourage you to check out stylecraft if
you have not checked it out
motionscience.tv
stylecraft s-t-y-l-e-c-r-a-f-t
[Music]
registration closes april 2nd i hope to
see many many of you there
until next time
my name is cameron and this is motion
science